down in the depths of facility 23 a
group of scientists stand before a
massive rumbling piece of machinery
they all hold their breath as the
gigantic mechanism suddenly stops
it's eerily quiet for a moment before a
door slides open
the scientists crane their necks to see
inside to see what the result of their
great experiment was
these were some of the greatest minds in
the scp foundation
but nothing could prepare them for what
they had created
september 9 2008 was an unseasonably
frosty day
when dr charles gears one of the scp
foundation's most
iconic scientists parked his honda civic
outside of what seemed like an innocuous
government cold storage warehouse
he sipped his coffee and surveyed the
building which he
along with about a hundred others in
total knew to be site
19 facility 23. why was dr
gears former director of all euclid
level containment at site 19 here today
because official testing was about to
begin on scp-914
the foundation had acquired the machine
now known as scp-914 some time ago
but only after its recent
reclassification to 914 had it been
relocated
to facility 23. it must have been
important
because the entirety of the facility was
being repurposed for scp-914 research
they were dealing with an immensely
complicated piece of anomalous
technology here
and the same question was on everybody's
lips what exactly does this thing do
dr arthur hackett the facility director
had requested the cold clinical
assistance of dr
gears in providing the answer once he'd
finish his morning coffee
dr gears headed inside the facility's
security chief
agent alan sedna had been beefing up
security at the building
and at least two mobile task force units
were already on call in case anything
happened
the first day of official testing is
always a crap shoot you might get a nice
drink out of it
like with scp-294 or you may get an xk
class
end of the world scenario you never
really know
all dr gears knew as he walked up the
granite steps to the main entrance
was that he was already feeling
exhausted when you've dealt with
anomalous objects and entities for
decades on end
the sense of wonder and mystery begins
to wear off only to be replaced with a
kind of tedium
any office worker knows all too well
everyone knew
that dr gears was devoted to the job
perhaps more than anyone else
but he approached the job with an
emotionless effect
you wouldn't know from looking at him if
he was thinking about the deadly
anomalous creature in the next room
or what he was going to have for lunch
that day the doctor passed through
security and was briefed in the break
room by dr
lucius veritas director of research at
site 19.
he explained that the machine seemed to
work in the absence of any power source
its mechanical structure is similar to
machinery from the industrial revolution
but it's exceedingly complex for
something constructed in that time
foundation analyses into the structure
of the 914 machine have shown it to have
as many as 8 million moving parts
and that might even be an incomplete
estimate dr gears wore his trademark
blank face as he listened
solemnly nodded and asked to be shown
the anomaly
he was led into containment chamber 109b
by a pair of guards
according to all current foundation
tests the machine doesn't appear to pose
any active risk of containment breach or
danger to the guards
earning it the rare safe designation as
a result
aside from guards stationed on site
containment procedures for 914 were
minimal
whether this designation would need to
be changed after testing
was something dr gears would soon find
out
scp-914 was a truly impressive site to
behold
a giant clockwork mechanism taking up
around 18 square feet
with an unfathomably complex combination
of screwdrives
belts pulleys springs and gears a less
stoic researcher might see the humor in
recruiting a dr
gears to test such a device but comedy
definitely wasn't one of dr gear's
specialties
he stared at the machine with a detached
fascination analyzing its vital
components at a glance
gears noted a large mainspring beneath a
rudimentary selection panel
the panel is copper with a large
selection knob fixed to an arrow above a
series of different options
rough coarse one-to-one fine
and very fine there was also a large key
below the selection panel
for the purposes of winding up the
mainspring and initiating whatever
procedure this machine was designed to
enact
next dr gears noticed two large booths
connected to the machine by a pair of
equally large copper tubes
the booth on the left labeled intake and
the right labeled output
incredibly dr gears was able to
immediately deduce the purpose of this
machine
it was designed to enact some kind of
transformative process
on whatever was placed into the intake
booth but what kind
of transformative process that's exactly
what dr
gears was here to find out the
experiment was simple
they would gather a series of samples
both inanimate objects and living tissue
and use them to explore the different
permutations of the 914 machine's
transformative abilities
this initial series of experiments were
approved by o5 command and the site
director
and with the 47 researchers present in
facility 23 at his disposal
dr gears commenced his research into
scp-914
to minimize risk dr gears decided the
first test would be a simple kilogram of
steel
on his orders the steel was placed into
the intake booth
with the doctor's approval a junior
researcher set the control panel setting
too rough
and began twisting the main spring key
at which point the booth doors closed
and a small bell inside shined
the machine began to rumble it's eight
million working pieces
churning into life it continued like
this for around 10 minutes before
falling silent
at which point the output booth opened
what had once been a single lump of
steel weighing one kilogram
was now an uneven pile of smaller lumps
with evidence of laser cutting
dr gears may note of the fact that
having lasers within such a machine is
both anachronistic
and anomalous and that the rough setting
appears to messily cleave the object
placed within the intake booth into
pieces
dr gears also noted that it would be
unwise to test any kind of explosive
material
on the rough setting unless of course
they wanted to destroy the building
the research continued dr gears used
another one kilogram lump of steel to
test the one-to-one feature
this time the result was far more
peculiar the output booth contained the
exact same weight and steel screws
this result was sparking even greater
connections in dr gear's impressive
analytical mind
firstly the one-to-one feature caused
the 914 machine to transform the output
into something different from but
similar to the intake
and while this would require further
testing it appeared that the 914 machine
despite being anomalous
does still follow the laws of physics
samples passed through the machine
conserve their mass
and would not be transmuted on an atomic
level from one element to another
next dr gears pushed another lump of
steel through the machine on the fine
setting
the result this time was a kilogram of
steel carpet tacks
from this dr gears was able to ascertain
that the fine feature
improves the samples placed within the
intake booth somewhat
however things got even stranger when
gears performed the same experiment on
the very fine setting
the output booth provided several
unknown gases and a lump of unknown
metal with anomalous qualities
namely it was resistant to heat up to 50
000 degrees
impossible to bend or break with any
force and was a perfect conductor of
electricity
dr gears suddenly realized his task here
may be more interesting than he'd
initially imagined
was that a bit of a smile on his face
that one researcher spotted
surely not this was the famous
unflappable dr gears after
all the doctor decided to take it up a
notch and began to test more complex
items in the 914 machine
he removed his own wristwatch and placed
it into the input booth
before setting the machine to course and
letting her rip
literally in this case when the output
booth was opened
the watch had been painstakingly
disassembled into its component parts
with no damage to said parts
dr gears noted the course feature as a
more mild version of the rough
in the sense that it was able to take an
object apart without any kind of
fundamental damage
he also made note of the fact he'd need
to get himself a new watch
dr gears then asked one of the
researchers to surrender their cell
phone for testing
while none were excited at the prospect
of their phone getting eviscerated by a
clockwork behemoth
one of the researchers eventually
surrendered their blackberry curve to
the doctor
he placed it into the intake booth on
the one-to-one setting
and ten minutes later the output booth
released a brand new
apple iphone sadly for the researcher
who donated his blackberry
he wasn't allowed to keep the new device
naturally
dr gears was interested in trying out
the anomalous very fine setting on a
more complex object
seeing as no other researchers were
eager to hand over their personal
effects
he took a cold python revolver from a
member of security
and ran that through the machine on very
fine the result was an extremely
powerful energy weapon containing gamma
radiation
which fired a beam capable of
disintegrating anything in its path
while the weapon's power was immense it
was also too dangerous and unstable to
be added to the foundation's armory for
general use
having collected a wealth of data from
more complex objects
dr gears was eager to move to the next
stage
live test subjects while his fellow
researchers had some reservations
the experiments pushed on beginning with
mice
a single white mouse was put into the
intake booth on the one-to-one setting
and the machine was activated the result
five minutes later was an
almost identical creature saved for the
fact that it now had brown fur
encouraged by the fact that the mouse
survived the refinery process
dr gears next applied for the use of two
chimps in his scp-914 experiments
the first chimp was run through the
machine on the fine setting the result
was a chimp of human level intelligence
who has since begun working for the
foundation under the alias dr bobo
and the data from this test has been
expunged from the official reports to
protect dr bobo's privacy
the second primate test this time on
rough was not quite as positive
the chimp was dismembered with the
mutilated corpse showing evidence of
cutting from high heat and crushing
of course everyone knew where these
tests were eventually going
dr gears requested two members of
d-class personnel for testing
the first was a 42 year old caucasian
male weighing 108 kilograms and standing
185 centimeters tall
dr gears ran him through scp-914 on the
one-to-one setting
resulting in a slightly taller hispanic
man with a slightly lower body weight
he immediately became severely confused
and agitated and attempted to attack the
guards present
leading to his unfortunate termination
by foundation staff
it was on the final live test that
tragedy truly struck
a 28 year old caucasian male was run
through the machine on the highly
anomalous very fine
setting the result was an utterly
nightmarish creature
so horrifying that the majority of the
details on its physical appearance have
been expunged from the report
the creature made a sudden escape
breaching the relatively minor
containment procedures intended for the
inert
scp-914 this highly dangerous creature
killed eight guards
as well as two senior researchers upon
emerging from the output booth
a special response team was dispatched
to take the creature down
but that proved harder than expected
scp-914 had massively improved upon the
human original
especially when it came to its killing
ability eventually it was captured
but the special response team suffered
injuries and memory loss as a result of
the creature's anomalous powers
the creature was also severely wounded
and its blood caused corrosive damage to
the plumbing in facility 23
the creature expired from its injuries
several hours later
turning into a cloud of blue ash that
blinded a nearby research team
dr gears would later comment that the
experiments were ultimately still a
success
in spite of some minor hiccups testing
on the device continues to this day
in an effort to understand the full
potential of the machine
though for obvious reasons biological
testing on the machine has since been
forbidden
without direct authorization from o5
command
after all if an already dangerous scp
was ever subjected to the very fine
transformation setting
we could be dealing with something
beyond our greatest nightmares
check out scp-5000 the suit and scp-102
the old man for more stories of the
strange and dangerous anomalies
under the watchful eye of the scp
foundation